hello and welcome to the shaky science
show so in this video we're going to
talk all about the company new relink
and what they are planning to do what
they are currently doing and how they're
going to achieve this and so in
particular we're going to be talking
about their brain machine interface and
what this device can do and what
developments are needed to further
improve the system and to improve the
safety because there's a lot of risk
associated with this technology but
there's a lot of excitement surrounding
this technology because it has the
potential to treat a number of diseases
from Parkinson's disease epilepsy to
depression and so we'll try and discuss
all of these different features in this
video so firstly that's just a bit
background about a newer length the
company itself so it's a newer
technology company and it was founded
back in 2016 by Illamasqua and others
and they as I said a developing and
implantable brain machine interface so
there is quite a lot to cover in this
video but broadly split it down firstly
we're going to focus on what are their
main goals so to help prepare for this
video I want the full video of the
neural link launch event and coursing
read the recent publication that Elon
Musk published last year that goes into
more detail about the technology of this
implantable device and so I've tried to
summarize base with these features into
this video and you'll find the link to
both of these sources in the description
so as I said we're going to look at your
links goals look at why they're doing
its how they're doing it and then where
they're currently at and their future
plans and clinical trials but first we
need to have a little bit of the basics
for neurons before we go any further so
I will try and keep this explanation as
simple as possible so what I've drawn
out here is a neuron so this is a very
generic looking neuron and so what
neurons do is they pass on signals and
they do this in one singular direction
and then at the end of the neuron it can
then very chemical signal pass on the
signal to the next neuron and say this
is the process of neural transmission so
besides these chemical signals
when it goes to three the neuron itself
it has an electrical signal and you can
record these electrical signals to see
if a neuron is active
so these neuro signals are often also
referred to as nerve impulses or action
potentials or spikes due to the trace
that they give if you measure the
voltage across the membrane of these
neurons so during one of these spikes
you see the membrane potential become
positive and the voltage go up and so
this happens because of the changes in
flux between the ions across the
membrane of the neuron so when the
neuron becomes stimulated you see an
increase in positive ions flow into the
inside of the neuron and this is what
causes the increase in the voltage and
then once this has increased the cars
there's been a secondary response close
this channel to prevent any more ions
coming in and our different channel
opens that allows different positive
ions to leave the neuron and the point
to take from this is that there's
electrical changes across the membrane
of the neuron due to these movements of
clients and these are what can be
detected and recorded to understand
which neurons are active so our brains
have around a hundred billion neurons so
that's a lot of information that we've
got in our brain and this information
isn't just which neurons are active or
inactive it also depends on the
frequency of these spikes and also their
timing however perturbations in neuronal
signaling can cause a variety of
different disorders such as epilepsy
depression and Parkinson's disease and
so one of the motivations behind your
link is to be able to understand and
treat these different brain disorders
and also potentially at some point a
longer term future goal is to preserve
and enhance your own brain and all know
it's to create a well aligned future and
as described in the launch meeting is to
have a full brain machine interface and
have a symbiosis with AI instead of it
working for us and the Feres of it
taking over so the mechanism by which
neural link want to treat these
disorders is through a brain machine
interface so what exactly does that mean
so apologies for the terrible drawing of
a brain
but what this means is that initially
you need to be able to detect these
electrical signals these spikes that
come from the different neurons and then
we need to be able to interpret these
signals and understand what it means and
then using that information you can then
feed back into the brain and stimulate
two different neurons and so this could
work either by taking the information to
the outside world or by having my direct
in vivo feedback system so how many
neurons would you have to detect to be
able to interpret the signal well as
many as possible studies have shown that
the greater the number of neurons can be
recorded the faith the best of the
predictions are and say that helps to
alleviate the problem that neuronal
signaling is somewhat stochastic so by
having more neurons the predictions can
be better so the last step of these
brain machine interfaces is the feedback
to the brain and so this is part of the
field of neuromodulation and what this
simply means is being able to regulate
this moderate neural activity and it's
actually a fast-growing area of medicine
and there's a lot of research in this at
the moment but the question is how so
there are a lot of emerging technologies
that are capable of this but the
approach that neural link have taken are
implantable technologies and this
requires the combined knowledge of
specialists in a variety of different
fields from robotics the materials
g'bye chemistry hello to FDA regulation
to software development and so neural
link have developed a variety of
different models and improved upon them
each time the one that they most
recently presented was an n1 sensor and
so the key components to this brain
machine interface include threads
robotics electronics and algorithms and
the three main goals by using this and
one sensor is to be able to increase by
orders of magnitudes the number of
neurons that they can read from and then
feed back empty in a manner that is safe
and long-lasting and then the importance
of this is that they could produce
devices that serve critical unmet
medical needs of patients and then also
they want to make the procedure of
integrating with this and
sensor or further developments of these
sensors in a simple and automated manner
such that it's as simple as having laser
eye surgery so if we look at the first
goal fast because it's fast the
implantable device must be able to
record the electrical signals and they
can do that by using electrodes and see
these are what are used to detect the
spikes and say there are around 1024
electrodes on these devices and in the
future they hope to have up to three
thousand and seventy two with each
electrodes potentially being able to
record thousands of neurons and so the
second question is how do you get these
sensors into the patient so in your
links goal is to meet the procedure as
simple and safe as possible and this
means having made big scars and no long
hospital stays so the current plan is to
use only a local anaesthetic whilst they
make a small opening in the skin and
then a painless opening in the skull and
then the idea is to use a robotic system
to have a quick placement of the threads
into the cortex and this is important
because the brain actually moves as we
break breathe and only a robot would be
able to get that precision and able to
avoid vasculature in the brain so as you
can see in this figure you can see that
the opening is then filled by the sensor
so that the scalp can be closed up and
then you can see how the threads are
placed into the brain cortex and so this
procedure will be so simple that you
wouldn't have to shave any hair off
which is a good thing but that is not
the only incision that needs to be made
to get the information from the
electrodes that also needs to be a small
incision behind the ear to insert a coil
and what this cool it does is it's
connected to the sensors 3ds wires and
then the last component is a wearable
device that connects wirelessly and is
also controlled by an iPhone app and
it's also the outside component that
could in theory be modified or upgraded
and it just reminds me of this bit from
Doctor Who nice reference if you're not
about to keep on anyway
what is needed to be able to achieve
this if we're gonna be realistic about
this well firstly you want it to be
completely wireless which is the
approach that they've taken but secondly
the big challenge is how long will these
last in the brain you need years the
decades in terms of a lifetime and
biocompatibility with the brain another
big challenge is having a practical
bandwidth and so a bandwidth is the
maximum rate of data transfer and so the
idea is to be able to minimize the delay
between detecting and then feedback into
the system and lastly in terms of
patients quality of life you want this
approach to be something that can be
used at home instead of having to go to
the hospital so development and
modification of these devices is an
ongoing process at neuro-link
and our many technical and biological
challenges that they face so you on a
technical sides the ideal solution would
be able to have single spike resolution
so you having a single neuron that
you're detecting so you need to get the
electrodes as close to the neurons as
possible but without causing any damage
and so you need small flexible devices
that are biocompatible with the brain
and then the system still needs to be
functional and so also needs to use
materials that are long-lasting as well
as being biocompatible and in addition
you want the manufacturing process and
the materials that are being used to be
scalable so that it has lots of
futuristic outlook could be applied more
globally so these challenges are more
focused on getting the device into the
brain and then being able to detect the
electrical signals the second challenge
comes from the biological side which is
being able to interpret what the signals
name and this is why you need algorithms
and correct interpretation of the
signals and say one way that they want
to do this is fastly by converting these
analog spike signals into a digital
signal and then use digital signals to
look for patterns and as one electron it
could detect more than one urine you
need to also be able to identify
different neurons that could be combined
in the same signal and so these spikes
really are communication with the brain
and so the idea is to be able to do this
and get the feedback in real time but
putting the challenges to one sides
with this information what could you
actually do so one example that I'll
explain is the treatment of paralysis so
there's a region in the brain known as
the primary motor cortex and this is
where signals are sensed and the spinal
cord to muscles to drive movement the
problem is this becomes defective in
patients with paralysis but the cool
thing is even just thinking of movement
stimulates a similar response to
actually performing the movement so the
way that I understand this is that if
you have a patient with paralysis and
they think about movement you could use
these sensors to detect that information
and then feed back into the system to
stimulate a part of the brain lap pool
and cause the movements also control
movement of assisted robotic devices and
so this could then be extended further
to other regions of the brain because
the motor cortex not only does it
control arm and hands movements but you
can also control speech and so in theory
in future you could have synthetic
speech and then as other brain regions
beyond that such as regions involved in
regulating moods pain hunger memory such
as the hippocampus which in theory could
also be targeted and used to treat other
diseases such as Parkinson's epilepsy
depression and chronic pain and so
neural link and visualize a future where
we could see individualized highly
focused treatments so these are more
long-term goals so where neural link
currently adds in terms of treatment of
diseases so it was outlined in that
launch event that they planned to
initiate human clinical trials by the
end of 2020 and say the aim for this
child would be to implant four of these
and one senses and to have three of them
in meat areas and one of them in this
multi-sensory area and they are planning
to do this in patients with quadriplegia
which is those patients who have damage
in their spinal cord so the plan is to
record neuronal activity in the mo and
SMA and PMT areas of the brain and then
to be able to feedback and stimulates
the s1 region and say
if you didn't really know these areas
mean to me to worry too much there's a
little mark there if you're interested
but the priority number one is the
safety of patients and that's one thing
we have discussed yet is what are the
risks associated with this technology I
just realized I should probably say what
are the hazards not what are the risks
but anyway fastly the what the issues
with this is getting the device in the
first place into the brain because there
could be damage associated with the
integration of the sensors and if thats
caused the surrounding tissue that could
cause inflammation which is known to be
linked with diseases such as aging and
Alzheimer's which isn't really what you
want to be inducing and the patients and
also there's several heat emission from
the sensors themselves which could also
lead to inflammation and scarring and
then what happens if the device actually
malfunctions you can't just remove them
very easily and then with the issue of
it being able to last a lifetime without
reading on causing potential byproducts
in the brain that could also cause
inflammation and then more related to
the feedback mechanism and stimulation
of neurons what happens if it becomes
uncontrollable and you end up with
unwanted and involuntary movements I
don't know why this reminds me this bit
from water sacrament but basically
there's a lot of issues and safety
hazards that need to be addressed so it
will be interesting to see what happens
in the clinical trials and then to await
the FDA approval but yeah there's many
problems still to be solved and
addressed and it's going to take time
and as I mention as well that there are
other emerging technologies as well but
what is exciting about neuro-link
approach is that they're very much
looking far into the future as to why
this technology could go and to leave
you on one of their endpoints their aim
is to have better connections to the
world to each other and to ourselves
and so hopefully this video has given
you somewhere overview to neuro-link
obviously I'm not related to the company
in any way I've just read this online
and try to explain it to you the best I
can so hopefully you've learned
something if you have something that
you'd like to say that I said wrong let
me know I'm happy to listen and learn as
well and as a way
that's listening